[Music]
nina is on the line in pensacola florida
nina welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for having me absolutely how
can john and i help
um i have a question about trying to
minimize the accumulation of interest on
my
um on my loans okay
on student loans
yes sir i have um i have federal student
loans i also have a private loan and i
have credit cards as well okay
so you want to minimize interest what
was the the thinking behind minimizing
interest just you you don't want to pay
more than you have to pay
yeah um
ideally i would love to be able to start
paying it off but realistically i'm in
an intensive
nursing program right now and i don't
graduate until after the summer of next
year um so i wouldn't be able to start
working to start paying it off so
um i actually tried to
transfer my credit card debt um
to get zero apr for at least a year try
to get that interest down
i don't know about loan consolidation if
that would help
but try to
get the interest down are you continuing
to take on debt as you finish this
program
i am
um
i am finding ways to pay for it um as
the semesters come i'm not taking any
more federal
loan that i'm not taking out any private
loans at the moment so what are you
taking out to pay for this
um the
the money that's been coming in from
covid
like um
the school's been sending me money for
clothes like um release funds and then
everything that supplement my parents
have been helping me to cover it yeah
okay well the interest has been paused
with the student relief
extension being in place until january
31st so february 1st payments are back
on interest back on and so the best
thing you can do is pay off your loans
while you can right now but it sounds
like you don't have the cash flow to do
that as you continue to finish this
program
so the only way to minimize interest on
your loans other than refinancing
getting a lower interest is to actually
pay off the debt as quickly as possible
and so that's why we recommend what's
called the debt snowball and it sounds
counterintuitive because what we say is
hey ignore the interest rate you're just
going to list the debts from smallest to
largest the balances you're going to pay
minimum payments on all of those debts
except for the smallest debt and on that
debt you're going to attack it with a
vengeance with everything you've got
with side job money any income you're
going to shave your expenses down to
bare bones and attack that debt because
once you do that you free up a payment
you are making on that debt and you use
that on the next debt and the next debt
and the next debt so that is truthfully
the best way to minimize interest is to
get rid of the debt as fast as
possible all right
since you're still in school and i do
know a special medical intensives
whether it's nursing or nurse
practitioners or you know you're in your
clinical rotations in med school
whatever
i understand those are those take up
your your your entire life you're
working 10 to 12 hour 14 hour shifts and
then you're doing class work at night
and then you're starting up and doing
that over again your goal right now is
to get through school with no more debt
stop the bleeding okay put a put a plug
in that in that drain so the water
doesn't keep coming out if you're trying
to fill up the drain doesn't matter if i
mean trying to fill up the sink doesn't
matter if the if it's just all draining
right back out the bottom so stop the
the drain stop the bleeding i'm going to
use as many metaphors i'm just going to
use 30 of them in this one a lot of
medical analysis
too many but stop that and then when you
get done with school you're going to
have to make a commitment to yourself
that you're going to do what george just
said put those debts in in order
smallest to largest and you're going to
start knocking them off then you're not
going to buy a new car you're not going
to go buy a new house with your big
nursing salary you're going to just
spend that first year that first two
years getting out of debt and you're
going to set yourself up for a lifetime
of
peace okay good for you